so have you guys seen this yeah like
their population would be cut in half
right cut in half did you see this
article it did not no yeah i just sent
it to you guys earlier today i don't
know if you had a chance to take a look
at it china's population could have
within the next 45 years new study warns
china's population could have like cut
in half within the next 45 years
researchers say previous estimates
may have severely underestimated the
pace of democratic democratic decline
census data says the birth rate was 1.3
children for each woman last year
well below the level needed to stop the
population from fall and go a little
lower you said it's 2.4 is what is u.s
is no 2.4 is for it to grow to grow 1.3
1.7 is level off gotcha 2.4 2.3 you're
growing china's population decline may
be much faster than expect the number of
people in the country having uh within
the next 45 years the projection was
based on the rate birth of 1.3 yeah so
but anyways going back to the
conversation we're having
if you're not going to put the time with
the kids man you know just you may want
to skip it's a lot of work today so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]